hello ladies and gentlemen to a new
video and today's video we're going to
be talking about the faction war now
someone in the past and like one of my
videos in the past couple days had asked
me to do a video on the faction war and
what it is how to win it what does
everything mean
so I kindly will take the time to
explain this to all of you now before
anybody asks yes I'm on the Knights and
this does look a little bit jumbled
which of which is how everything is
looking right now I know I'm kind of
we're kind of midway through a fight
here but what is faction more faction
war is a three-way battle between the
three factions of four honor the samurai
the Vikings and the Knights
we're at the start of the game a person
will pledge their allegiance to one of
the three factions the Knights the
Vikings of the samurai and then battle
with that team to take over all of the
land in the faction won now to win
faction more per se is to we everybody
assumes to have the most land now the
way the faction work the faction war
works though it is five rounds in one
season and one round the last 15 days so
that's about roughly three months worth
of one war until the season is over
after the first season is over every one
of us gets a new from the heroes
perfection one samurai one Viking one
night and then we do another season
infection work now you'll see here that
there's a bunch of you know extra-mile
red x's blue x's basically what's going
on is that the blue is the samurai
territory in this example and the yellow
is the knight territory my faction so
after you complete a game you will give
you'll be given war assets war assets
are what you deploy to fight for those
territories in this situation the
samurai have more war assets than the
knights do in these three territories
that's why those are that's why there's
a blue cross like X on that spot meaning
that after the next character
we update in the top right that says 3
hours and 47 minutes if they still have
that controlled they will take that over
same goes with the Vikings and the
samurai over here on our territory while
we're going to [ __ ] now another thing
I noticed is that we have three
different game modes Dominion duel and
brawl and then the deathmatch playlet
one thing you have to note is that yes
you can play Dominion but like oh I like
playing Dominion but our friends or our
team is getting [ __ ] on over here or
so play some war assets one thing you
want to keep in mind is that if you play
a certain game mode like deathmatch and
you deploy your assets on the deathmatch
area you get more war assets than if you
were to deploy them over here on
Dominion it just makes it so that the
game kind of wants you to play that game
mode in that specific spot it's not too
bad but it's kind of useful and like
when you're down like maybe 10 minutes
left right now it's not too bad because
I mean it was just it just kind of
switched so their boss it's super early
not everyone's up right now now after
this I will be I'm going to play a match
and then I will explain to you what most
of this stuff means when I get back
alright so now that the game is over
which was a really simple game just a
1v1 against the bots I get some XP I get
some other stuff you go to next match
and you deploy the war assets now a lot
of this is going to sound a really
confusing and the right I'll explain all
of it basically
so these war assets in these in this
section for the deathmatch you get a
personal match bonus which was the 60 I
got from playing now you're going to get
another 20% which is just an extra 12
because you're playing in the game mode
that you're deploying in eventually it's
going to get a lot more interesting like
for the Vikings here where they're super
close to their own territory so they're
going to get more war assets to deploy
because they're getting their ass beat
the closer you are to the closer an
enemy is to your stronghold the more at
war assets you'll be able to deploy in
these sections here not as you can see
look at that
they have 38% and they have 61 and I bet
you no one's even touched
it's just because they have so much it's
just because they're really close to
that objective now like I would I
thought about this during the match you
don't have to pledge your allegiance to
one group and then stick with that group
you can leave that the event mid-match
or you can leave these groups you know
midseason let's say hmm the Vikings are
always getting [ __ ] over I don't like
the Vikings I want to move to the
samurai or to the Knights you can do
that but you won't get your reward at
the end of the season now we don't know
no one knows if you get any reward at
the end of the round after eight days
because it's only the first round no one
knows yet so maybe you can get rewards
and you just only can't get rewards for
the first round and then if you switch
if you don't switch any of the other
times you'll be fine no one knows that
yet no one also knows what happens when
you fully take over someone's stronghold
see as the Vikings are getting their ass
beat nobody knows yet people have
assumed that if you take over the
stronghold any red whatever group takes
over the stronghold any red in this case
for the Vikings any red tile will become
theirs so if the Knights take over the
Vikings and their stronghold any red
will become ours and it will become
yellow so that means it's just a 2-way
battle between us of the samurai we
don't know how they get back into the
war or if we're going for the whole
round and they can't come back we have
no clue yet we everybody's just been
killing it just so that we can find out
another thing you can do is that if you
like for example the Knights you don't
have to stick with their heroes as you
can see here I'm a knight player I
pledge my allegiance to these Knights
and I've only used lawbreaker about for
about maybe seven games yes I'm the only
person I've really been using is Ken's a
and he's a samurai so clearly I can use
the samurai but still be as a vitac era
as a knight it's kind of weird kind of
awkward when you see that but it really
doesn't matter it's everybody's choice
those are just some of the things you'll
see in faction war thank you to the
person that requested me to do this I'm
I'm all here for all of you
if you have any other video ideas you
want me to cover whether there's the
connection error for the game or
something else is going on it doesn't
seem right that's completely fine I will
gladly go over that these are just some
of the this is just some of the options
you have here during faction war hope
you all did enjoy subscribe for more
videos if you want them like the video
if you did enjoy this like it if you
didn't enjoy and then I will see you all
in the next video peace out